hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to episode two of drunk
minecraft season two I'm here with Bob
and Wade introduce yourselves well hi
everybody I damn it Wade Oh
introduce yourself I'm still Lord minion
seven seven seven Wade uh that's Bob
that's mark see our point I don't know
which way they are yeah okay
all right okay we wait and I'll wait
yours are you sure to mention it I don't
know were suppose we doing that now
hahaha it'll mark runs YouTube channel
as you yeah yeah okay yeah and we're
once again on the server of zombie mold
check the description there's a bunch of
links in the description check it for
anything you you have an idea for write
to me my firm on Twitter yeah twitter
twitter cuz i like twitter okay so if
you see here we've got a giant pit of
death on our platform from the last
episode oh it's good me from the last
episode what we're doing here is we've
got a little friendly competition going
on where we are gonna try to build the
best house that we can but there are
some restrictions and limitations to
what we can use to build that are in
these magical chests now since bob was
the big winner from the last game he is
to pick he gets to pick a chest and if
he likes it he can take it or he can
forfeit it and pick again from the other
two buzz what he looks at it and doesn't
take it and then he looks into another
chest he can't go back to the first yeah
make the second check yeah he has to so
Bob can pick and he will pick right now
right now right now no no right now Oh
honestly that's probably the middle
chest but I'm gonna go higher okay
yes oh so big lasers cactus is by far
well I know which one I'm picking wait
yeah wait a minute what did you get
cuz this doesn't seem that richer that's
the [ __ ] one hahahahahahaha
onion haha wait wait go screw yourself
with your lava okay now that we are here
we've got our eye in the sky I have this
photo photo photo photo dadadada baby
photo da da da da
hahahahaha oh boy
okay okay and we've got our giant clock
up there once that clock starts and my
clock starts just in case that clock
breaks cuz it's made of redstone oh we
are we have 20 minutes to build the best
house that we can out of the materials
provided we cannot PvP but if someone is
standing on the edge and they get pushed
off that is their [ __ ] also I have a
three stacks of quartz haha alright
alright alright stop bragging about what
you got are we good why wait stop what
you're waiting Seiko yet oh yes see
Wade's a big cheater booth doesn't
listen very well no he does not wait to
get some Flint I plated gravels okay
okay the house must be built on this
stone platform here must fit within the
constraints we have allow whatever
creativity that we have we can sabotage
other people's houses all we want but we
don't have the tools to do so nor Armour
to protect ourselves are we ready
gentlemen yes yes let us begin in 3 2 1
go
Camaro
yeah uh-uh no what you're building there
Bob I'm gonna build the Emerald City
from The Wizard of Oz okay that sounds
good yeah I'm going to build
Oh what an Enderman is in play ha ha ha
Oh everything wait how the hell am I
gonna get down I did not think this
through I did not think this through
okay no one grabbed my stuff
no I grabbed my Duff no one grabbed my
stuff wait if you grab my stuff I will
murder you will you wait bother it's
tough do not burn my stuff hang on
do not wait oh you just over drove your
mic so hard that it cut out not on my
end everything got recorded just fine so
doesn't matter don't matter for yo okay
alright so now that we're we're
coordinating let's get some
interpretation of what everyone else is
building Bob seems to be doing an
excellent version of the Emerald City
wait is making a penis as far as I can
tell ah such typical such typical Wade
fashion with the penis maneuver you can
see that it's made of gravel and stone
and I have wood and brick what exactly
do you have Bob I'm cute I've got three
stacks of quartz
oh [ __ ] that's all my emerald I've got
two stacks of stone bricks three stacks
of spruce wood planks a stack of
redstone a stack of redstone lamps uh uh
a cup chiseled stone a set of stone
tools stack of paintings stack of
torches stack of redstone torches uh-huh
very interesting Oh what are you
drinking there Bob I am drinking the
same thing I was earlier exhibit this
time as I'm showing your viewers and
show them in in the intro my bottle of
bourbon is empty hahaha so we've been
drinking quite a bit uh wait what are
you drinking I'm drinking another
inkling another one is almost done with
the third Yingling third Jesus pick it
up man this is my uh hey let me
clarified third since we started the
first drunk minecraft uh seventh since
we started ok prepping for what we're
doing here this is my fourth vodka and
grape soda and they are delicious
they're delectable it's great vodka and
grape soda is it not yes that's a great
bottom great coach it is it tastes like
candy it is amazing I love it
and I place wood in the wrong spot okay
all right okay uh-huh
so now I've actually never seen quarts
what does it look like looks like white
kinda looks like white wool except much
more not woolly uh uh okay that a good
description no it's not but I'll allow
it
wait wait building a penis volcano ha ha
ha ha oh please stop please tell me it's
true is it a penis volcano judging by
our giant clock we have 17 minutes left
and the the buildings are already taking
proper shape so with that said what are
you doing wait I have no idea I've got
crappy much oh come on you gotta have
some plan I've got a I've got him a what
he's doing no he didn't you did not no
he did not wait what do you have I'm
interested I hope you sacks of sand a
stack gravel and two stacks of
cobblestone it hahahahahahah cup of dirt
ha ha ha ha it's got dirt
give me a Dean move on oh it was was it
an effort dear calf and move on down the
line oh what's the head more glass oh
poor baby with your amazing materials
shut up do not see the masterpiece that
I am building no the glorious epic
effigy effigy someone correct me effigy
oh is it effigy
oh you're going for so yes glorious
monument to my own incredible miss at a
markiplier statue yes ah don't miss
that's really small it's Ibiza session
have you not seen your what I am
building
haha have you not seen your peers so
amazing structure with which I shall
dominate the competition Oh clearly it's
not your penis then oh oh you seem to be
pretty obsessed with my penis there Wade
so ha ha ha ha ha thank you
oh I did not want to do that do what
that's a horrible horrible mistake oh
thank God course is easy to break
hey Wade look up see you see you see
that you see you see that I can I get
more lava no what do you need lava for
you'll see what I had to work with hey
just give him a bucket and go down into
the pit of lava and see what you can do
here yeah what you with your problem
Wade what's your problem
yeah yeah you're structure looks like
crap
Oh does it Oh or is it glorious in every
way no oh no oh no better than yours no
yours looks like a giant pile of crap it
is well at least you admit it and it's
gonna go bye-bye
hey Wade look up this is you see yes
yeah
you see ya nope you're ready to fall and
die you'll never get here Wade you'll
never get here take that you suck I rock
no no it's lava get a bucket like you
should a bucket you're somebody iron
that we had in the last video and deal
with it the one that we had Zhong zu ha
ha ha yeah that one
okay yeah oh no I don't have enough
brick for my master plan
Oh No what am I gonna do
Bob how's yours coming along pretty good
okay blow it up well I don't have any
TNT but it's not a bad idea great course
with your bare hand you don't get the
block huh oh so it's like glass wait
you're breaking is I are doing down
there nothing I just I was just stating
facts what are you doing down there
don't sabotage any other people's houses
that's not how this game goes this is a
fair and even-handed you just gotta
taged mine ha ha ha I love breaking my
stuff
oh there was a game Bob come here you
know I have tools and weapons right ha
I'll go I'll come here right here
there's a course block that's missing I
see what you're getting at oh oh I still
I picked up all your materials oh no oh
no the back silly fellow
they fell into the fire shit's on fire
what put it out wait hostage wait what
are you doing who who said my house on
fire who did it all of my stuff oh wait
it was explicitly no pvp there was it
yes it was
don't the point oh yeah okay
oh oh yeah no why is my effigy to
greatness your stuffs right here
oh right like paintings and stuff Wow
yeah he had a pretty nice setup there I
had a nice Tower and now there's just
kind of a crooked penis up in the sky
well just a link to the server I'm like
I'm in trouble
hey what that wait stop it seriously
Apple ruin EVP no there wasn't that was
one of the rules I'll throw your stuff
back oh geez wait God you see everyone
out there everyone in the first seasonal
drunk minecraft we've kept that is why
during her minutes left I don't know
there's two one there's one
I don't read very well all right
everybody out there everyone out there
ooh
everyone was like oh man aren't you
little mean to wait and like no worries
not into the way we're not mean to wade
because way does it day those my glass I
just put it in this chest for ya Bob
took it there's my buckets Bob your
stuff is right here on the ground
Oh Wade you're such a dick oh you
started the war by putting water carry
our mark come here come here it was
sabotage houses not murder each other
thank you you and getting your material
let's sabotage your health by transition
right right right yeah whatever
mathematically flawless it's what you
heard you don't even make any sense Wade
uh looks I guess I'm not gonna complain
hahaha
we could pick up plane to the giant
camera in the sky yeah yeah that my
house was the first one victimized it
was you anything to you you stole for
Bert's haha see that yeah where you're
not even paying attention when I gave
the rules Wade I was not the first one
to murder I just want to point that out
no one killed you
to be fair I killed him oh you did he
took my course oh okay I did not take
your course I broke one Bluff to see if
I could and I could because hahahahaha
SH was permitted oh okay yeah Bob come
on man Bob first PvP R okay Bob it is
it's it's now apparent that Bob is the
cause of these troubles that we're
having it so yeah
suck on that way but we still hate we
still hate Wade hell that's nothing new
he's a douche yeah probably he's a
douche I'm not okay oh oh oh oh that was
close okay I'm okay
okay went to go check out this new um
this new Lake spot property over here
our materials uh-huh there's a skeleton
in my magical thing in the sky can you
put some materials in Wade's chest so
that he can once again commence the
building he didn't say what quality make
it good quality hahaha wait zombie use
your own destroy quality use your own
discretion zombie do whatever you feel
is right I'm going to sit here and drink
but how are we supposed to get to said
check ooh ooh ooh what's wrong
Oh huh Oh Shawn TEI Irie Ramon meat wah
is so laate only du fromage hello uh
that applies to you cuz you're Dexter
Han all right this better be worth it
because it's gonna take a while to get
to this let's switch to the view in the
sky Oh son of a [ __ ] put faster uh okay
this is gonna take a while
hi hoot I heard something wha
no wait how are you gonna get back from
there Wade what was in there why are you
good - quiet what is going on
am I alone here yeah I know what you
were doing Wade what and I do not
approve of it at all are you guys
breaking my [ __ ] again are you
no ha ha ha hey anything goes when it
comes to the chests and if I can't have
it then you can't have it either
Jackie ah I'm still alive I'm still
Harlan I'm still alive
ha ha
what was in that chest anyway Wade
quartz basically I don't know I think
it's just to look at it all ha ha ha ha
ha oh well it was a deserve it
eight how much time we got left Bob ah
Clarkson ah this son of a [ __ ]
Oh seven no I'll burn everything at this
club hahaha you uh I think Bob's gonna
win by default here let's start the
murder spree ah nah he's just sneaky
he's sneaky like that he's very very
clever he's very clever zaire anything
in my chest there's one Flint in my
chest
out of my ass you douchebag I'm not in
your house okay I'm not a spirit you're
not a douchebag then just get out of my
house you rich people are all the same
stepping on the poor one day we shall
rise up and you will get your justice
art yeah that's that's the end result of
my house I guess that's it because I
have nothing else
don't wait a puddle of Oh Oh doh
oh no Bob did you read the broadcast ah
good thing my house is impervious to
creeper attacks but Bob suicide bomb Oh
yuck ha ha ha ha ha hey it's all fair
right in the end you're still probably
gonna look better than ours we have five
minutes left and one emerald block it
would be better than hell oh my god is
so many ah there's five minutes left
suicide bomb okay I'm starting over I
want it to be known I want to be judged
on my second house on my first day ha ha
ha ha well we'll see oh I see what you
did Bob that's very clever right that's
quite clever
if I had anything to build with I would
continue on mine are you guys out of
stuff already yeah we're out of stuff a
long time
haha I don't think these buns were
scaled evenly to highlight something hey
it was your idea to make the last one so
shitty one that you got should have
allowed you to make something I still
don't know how mine caught fire oh it
was OHS you wait oh okay I used my only
lava on my house well how did mine catch
fire I have no clue that's leaves it do
it I don't have a single thing that can
start a fire so I have nobody I didn't
have a flint and steel or anything boom
I'm sabotaging your house if I can't get
bobs I'm getting yours way there's
nothing here to sabotage you have
emerald I saw emerald I stole up from
the remains of Bob's hahahahaha douche
bags you know Molly's texting me hi
now texting with relationship errs no
doing that just cuz I'm sadden alone
means I'm gonna take the rest of you
with me alright I gotta make one last
finishing desperate touch to my penis
tower of water you even get to it I'm
swimming up currently very slowly
how Hey oh hell man
dude you son of a [ __ ] no no pee pee
now you're swimming up even slower why
you're such an [ __ ]
I had one block of emerald that was it I
was gonna put an emerald stud on the tip
of my penis and you just ruined it
that's what you're saying I'm not if the
world from that [ __ ] I'm not gonna make
it up in time wait there's there's three
minutes there's less than three minutes
left till you got it I don't know I
don't think I'm gonna make it at this
rate hi wait how are you doing ma'am
I'll slow I just picked up speed like a
lot yes there's gonna be great I have
nothing else to build with but at least
I'm gonna have this oh wait no oh no no
no this wonderful doesn't touch the
penis
hahaha yeah God wait no I can make it I
can make it I can make it that's the
best thing anyone's ever said I got I
got this I got this
I gotta get rid of this one hang on I
got this oh come on it takes forever to
break brick there's two minutes left
that clock is surprisingly accurate I'm
impressed with that and boom oh yeah you
see this you see this wait Bob you see
this
Bobby's a hand wait wait
do your mom's so uneven the rest of shut
up Bob hang on you're getting a visitor
ah yeah oh man I get it
gotta get it gotta get it gotta getta
getta getta getta getting anything else
have weapons right do you have weapons
oh I was gonna make it I was gonna make
it oh how about hanging up over there
I'll be back I'm coming back you're
coming back I'm coming back I gotta get
up the waterfall in a minute and then
back onto your house I'm going to
destroy it
ah what I don't even know how Bob got
weapons his mother I think they were in
his chest
what hey the sooner fair Bob should have
gotten that the mediocre chest mom shut
economy do architects it's not fair it's
not fair Bob Bob is not fair there's
less than a minute left 45 seconds left
put the finishing touches on your bus
well I got nothing to put anything on
mine so I'm just gonna stand on mine I'm
gonna stand right here as we watch the
clock tick down to the end hi Wade
hey Mark hi time is up Oh time is up
time is up
Bob still building he loses but I don't
think it works out all right
you move all right let's take a good
look at these old Wade you you put a
painting on yours let me go see that oh
it looks nice who did me yeah you got a
painting on yours
all your Demerol Tower almost coincide
with the Emerald stud in my penis and
almost does is almost right there it
would have been ah man we could have
combined our towers and tried to be
Bob's okay so zombie magical eye in the
sky judge and be judge has a torch on it
who has won this horrifying competition
I built the most with the least
hmm I built the most with the most inner
douche bags I actually built a penis
which was like I can't believe everyone
else didn't go for that but I guess
that's just me
balls are uneven huh hey the balls are
always uneven it's natural that's true
you couldn't sit down if they weren't so
yeah exactly
that's why fair enough but what long
they're not like different never Munt
you know what never mind they're good
they're pretty you say there's a lump oh
no in the face of adversity with limited
means ah not wait Oh No why it's so ugly
is horrible
why did weight win what the hell why
can't we be friends like bull that is
bull okay and I said I'm the sky okay
free fall I'm gonna all right all right
okay all right okay all right so I'm
gonna I'm gonna say something before you
do your outro Wade because it's totally
not fair if you in for all the commoners
out there who do you think has the best
house of these like do you agree do you
agree with what now Bob Bob's a
ramshackle horrifying mag animation of
of awfulness always connecting the
houses basically viewers mark wants to
know if you're gonna side with him and
be a suck-up haha honest opinion and
write in the comments below what you
think is the best house of these who did
the best with what they had destroy my
I didn't do nothing anyway all right so
that is it Wade you have won
I do not agree with it but I will abide
by the rules unlike you did the dude
abides the dude abides so Wade please
send us off all right thank you guys so
much for watching this has been
markiplier moist skirm and Lord minion
777 moist skirm why skirm moisture let's
say it's always been my skin i skirm I'm
drunk shut up
drunk I know how to say it and I don't
want to say I and sobered somber ayat so
Bert what the hell is sober sober I ah
douche bag hey this is me burning lows
me and Bob burning together in some kind
of weird erotic fantasy dude outro
get it done thank you so much for
watching stay tuned for drunk minecraft
season 2 episode 3 until next time bye
bye everybody